hello everybody and welcome to part 14
of let's play penumbra overture
we got a puzzle ahead of us I just
finished up with motor II fixed
everything up soos okay that one's empty
that one's empty this one first one that
one that one this back one wait there
until that one and I can go to those
ones and then I don't know maybe I can
sprint it to the end I'm not sure
whatever I'll wing it
let me see you again okay AHA here here
and then this one's over here
thanks back here Wow okay this was over
here dude yeah I go here ah uh oh I
failed okay I fail I'm an idiot
big fat [ __ ] yeah like why didn't I run
I press the shift button I went it
slower okay this one still this one
waiting on the ah go back here ah [ __ ]
you ah right
let me just look real close huh the
order this 1.1.1 stay there go there up
over to there stay go up one more and
then run maybe no
I don't know I don't know okay here we
go ah uh uh yeah okay stay here for one
more one more
llama llama yeah oh I'm so great ah go
here
alright kinda go over there and then ah
[ __ ] oh that was the right one ah so
dumb you there then Oh
over there I'm so stupid and then over
there and we went up and then I can make
it oh [ __ ] back bud you okay here and
here here either way one more heart go
go oh yeah they're here and then wait
for it and then boom ah ah oh you're all
enjoying this aren't you laughing at my
misery right there then there when there
must be one more in between that okay ah
that corner one and then ah I see it I
see it I see it I see it oh I see it I
see it
that that that okay ah aha here and wait
wait and it go
no I didn't wait ah I'm so stupid don't
do it
oh oh
so go bet ah here hair hair
let that one go and wait one more got it
so smart here and here and then here and
then here and then o on the best ever
oh look at me all you know hotness vent
from me so great oh yeah I'm like Gordon
Freeman yeah what's up there yeah yeah
yeah I'm so great well this is exactly
that Gordon Freeman have left one of the
first events went in ramped up and then
goes to that room of water if you all
remember that ah come on
oh I guess that's an invulnerable one
why did I even come up here then oh I
know why come on hit it fine jeez
useless useless
totally useless okay all right
oh nothing absolutely dick did nothing
not at all
fine god oh come on that wasn't a way
the other way
why did I come through here it's all
bull oh don't tell me oh there was about
there oh no oh I'm so dumb
oh I'm so dumb oh I can't even get to
that valve okay I don't feel so bad
can't change oh I know oh I'm so smart
that's why these girls were here ah get
straight barrel get get I swear to god
barrel there we go
ah right now I can get here and get here
oh don't tell me oh no oh no no no no
I'm trying up oh come on oh this is
embarrassing
all this is so embarrassing why can't I
okay I do this oh I can't I oh why can't
I
ah so dumb okay alright so dumb I
apologize Peter I apologize for this I
thought I was smart
turns out I was dumb that doesn't happen
very often but it happened oh oh
ah fine ah no [ __ ] you think I'm so good
at this
here we go oh yeah on here and then wait
one more yeah Oh so leap oh I'm so great
oh look at me go yeah oh yeah one more
Shh Oh done like it ain't no thing
alright what the hell anyway still what
the hell ah
alright this door is jammed jammed shut
Oh even my Gigantor muscles can't open
yeah yeah yeah get it out of here
alright for some reason this is here it
must exist for a reason but what is that
reason why why are you why why do you
exist why do you exist
uh-uh anyway this must lead to somewhere
haha oh I get it oh maybe maybe I don't
get it
maybe it made me I probably don't get it
oh maybe try the hammer bonk bonk
dynamite down am i dead [ __ ] up boom Oh
boom nope alright that's impenetrable Oh
pain in the butt pain in the butt pain
in the butt
alright fine I'll go somewhere else
I don't need you I don't need any of you
well I'm not another beaut I need all of
you so so so very good to me
ah iron men a shaft Mike my Jeff I know
what I'm doing that was just a joke of
course I got bolt cutters can I do
anything
nope how's that gonna work it's gonna
cut the bolts stupid nope ah [ __ ] you uh
saw maybe no not quite right maybe let
me try something
let me try let me just give it a try
bolt cutters here maybe nope nope not
even imma go let me try it now you're
gonna insult me with a response fine
Oh so lost so lost why would this lead
so perfectly to there if it didn't want
me to be in there God
so try this again ah yeah now take you
with me
oh yeah so smart oh yeah I think I'm
gonna drop you right in there oh yeah
just like that
so I can get out well I got the
permanent finger going go alright nope
oh no no not again oh no all right guys
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry sorry I'm
sorry I'm so sorry okay
anyway there's nothing for me over there
not a thing not a damn thing I'm going
back to the way I came cuz that is bull
is all bull all the time
God Wow goose chase
ah but there's nothing here why why is
it why I don't know I don't know I don't
know maybe I'm not ready maybe I'm not
ready I'm probably not ready I'm not
mature enough to handle that area oh
don't get dark on me oh I don't even
know I don't even know I don't even know
I don't even know if I'm quick I'm so
quick oh oh what's up here ah oh no wait
that's nothing I never
dum-dum-dum uh yeah yeah okay oh right
ah app this yeah
ah I forgot oh okay all right all right
I'm just gonna pause it here I'm gonna
figure this out so you all don't have to
suffer through my idiocy thank you so
much for watching I will see you in part
15 buh-bye